[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute zeige ich euch
mein jahre lang bewährtes
lieblingsrezept für lassan ja total
unkompliziert und super lecker genau so
wie sich das gehört
[Musik]
wir starten zuallererst mit der
bolognese soße und hierfür benötigen wir
500 gramm rinder hackfleisch zwei bis
drei esslöffel öl 500 gramm passierte
tomaten 700 milliliter gemüsebrühe vier
möhren die habe ich klein geschnitten
außerdem zwei fein gehackte zwiebeln
sowie zwei fein gehackte knoblauchzehen
und einiges an gewürzen um euch nicht zu
langweilen schreibe ich euch die in die
infobox
[Musik]
zuallererst wird das öl in der pfanne
erhitzt und anschließend die zwiebeln
darin glasig gebraten
anschließend geben wir die
knoblauchzehen hinzu die werden darin
einmal ganz kurz mit gedünstet und dann
gehen wir auch schon das hackfleisch mit
in die pfanne
das fleisch wird nun rundherum
angebraten bis es gar ist oder wie man
so schön sagt das wird krümelig gebraten
bis wir dann die gewürze hinzugeben
sobald die gewürze dann kurz
untergerührt wurden wird das ganze mit
passierten tomaten und gemüsebrühe
abgelöscht
[Musik]
das ganze lassen wir dann köcheln ich
gebe aber vorher auch schon die möhren
mit hinzu damit sie schön durch jahren
können
was beim einer lasagne nie fehlen darf
ist meist den habe ich am anfang leider
in den zutaten nicht erwähnte ist
natürlich auch völlig optional genauso
wie die möhren für mich gehört er aber
immer mit dazu
mit geschlossenem deckel lassen wir das
ganze dann 15 bis 20 minuten köcheln
rühren dabei immer wieder um und dann
ist die bolognese soße auch schon fertig
[Musik]
für die becher mit soße benötigen wir
700 milliliter milch 60 gramm mehl 60
gramm butter 100 gramm käse ich habe
hier gouda verwendet und an gewürzen
pfeffer salz und muskatnuss
[Musik]
zuallererst bereiten wir die milch
spitze zu hilfe wird die butter in der
pfanne erhitzt und hier bitte nicht die
höchste stufe verwenden da die butter
sonst ganz schnell anbrennt sobald die
mutter dann flüssig ist geben wir in
einem schwung das mehl mit hinzu und
rühren dabei ständig um
sobald die masse dann so aussieht als
würde sie quasi atmen auch wenn sich das
komisch anhört geben wir dann ein
schlückchen weise die milch mit hinzu
mit sich hier keine dauerhaften
klümpchen bilden müsst ihr wirklich
ständig umrühren und das ganze nicht aus
den augen lassen
[Musik]
sobald ihr dann die gesamte milch 1
gearbeitet habt könnt ihr den herd auch
wieder aufschalten das ganze einmal
aufkochen lassen und hier auch wieder
nicht aufhören umzurühren zwischendurch
könnt ihr dann auch schon die gewürze
mit unterrühren
sobald die soße dann aufkocht legt sie
auch schon ein wenig ein
dann können wir den herd runterschalten
und geben den käse mit hinzu
den käse lassen wir dann in der heißen
masse schmelzen und dann ist die welcher
mail soße auch schon fertig
selbstverständlich könnt ihr die becher
mail soße auch ganz einfach weglassen
allerdings schmeckt die lassen hier dann
nicht so lecker wie sie soll
wir sind die letzten drei zutaten die
wir für unsere lasagne benötigen und
zwar sind das einmal diese lasagne
blätter außerdem creme fraiche und ein
wenig oder käse
nun wird die lasagne endlich geschichtet
und wir starten mit der becher mit soße
die gebe ich ihn mag ganz unten in die
auflaufform damit die nudel blättchen
auch später nicht ankleben
[Musik]
nachdem wir dann die lasagne platten
darauf verteilt habt geben wir von der
bolognese soße drauf und verteilen sie
auch nochmal gleichmäßig
[Musik]
nachdem ich darüber dann nochmal lasagne
platten verteilt habe verfahre ich so
dass sich auf die lasagne platten immer
besser mit sauce geben schön verstreiche
darüber kommt dann erneut bolognese soße
und immer so weiter
[Musik]
in meiner lasagne muss einmal mindestens
noch käse geschichte sein und zwar mache
ich das meistens mit ich da gebe ich
dann noch mal eine handvoll käse auf die
bolognese soße und schichtet dann erneut
la seien die platten darüber
[Musik]
eine lasagne endet immer mit einer
schicht bolognese und darüber verteile
ich dann 200 gramm creme fraiche die
gebe ich erstmal esslöffel weise drauf
und dann verteidigt das gleichmäßig
[Musik]
zu guter letzt noch eine handvoll käse
oder auch zwei und dann wandert die lasa
nie in den ofen bei 200 grad ober und
unterhitze für ca 35 minuten und so
lecker sieht meine lasagne dann fertig
aus nach dem backen lasst ihr sie am
besten noch zehn minuten stehen und dann
könnte sie auch schon anschneiden und
genießen
wie immer findet ihr die genauen
mengenangaben unten in der infobox und
falls ihr fragen habt dann schreibt sie
mir gerne in die kommentarfunktion
ansonsten freue ich mich wenn ihr main
kanal abonniert damit ihr auch keines
meiner videos mehr verpasst bis zum
nächsten mal tschüss
[Musik]